the surface area of a cube is equal to
the sum of the areas of its six sides
let's just visualize that i like to
visualize things so if that's the cube
that's the cube we can see three sides
three sides are facing us but then if it
was transparent we see that there are
actually six sides of a cube so there's
this one one two three in front and then
one this is the bottom this is in the
back and this is also in the back so you
have three sides of the cube so i
believe what they're saying
the surface area of a cube with side
length x so if this is x if this is x if
this is x is given by the expression 6 x
squared that also makes sense the area
of each side is going to be x times x is
x squared and there are six of them so
it's going to be 6x squared
jolene has two cube shaped containers
that she wants to paint one cube has
side length two so this is one cube
right over here let me do my best to
draw it
so this right over here has side length
two
so that's its dimensions the other cube
has side length 1.5
so the other cube is going to be a
little bit smaller
it has side length
1.5 so it's 1.5 by 1.5 by 1.1.5
what is the total surface area that she
has to paint
well we know that the surface area of
each cube is going to be 6x squared
where x is the dimensions of that cube
so the surface area of this cube right
over here is going to be 6
and now let me do it in that color of
that cube it's going to be 6 times x
where x is the dimension of the cube and
the cue ball has the same dimensions or
its length width and depth is all the
same so for this cube the surface area
is going to be 6 times 2 squared so it's
going to be 6 times 2 squared
and then the surface area of this cube
is going to be
is going to be 6 times
1.5 squared
1.5 squared and if we want the total
surface hair she has to paint it's going
to be the sum of the two cubes so we're
just going to add these two things
and so if we were to compute this first
one right over here this is going to be
6 times 4
this is 24
and this one right over here this is
going to be a little bit hairier let's
see 15 times 15 is 225 so 1.5 times 1.5
is
2.25
so this is going to be
so 1.5 squared is 2.25
and
2.25 times
6 so let me just multiply that out 2.25
times 6.
let's see we're going to have 6 times 5
is 30 6 times 2 is 12 plus 3 is 15
6 times 2 is 12 plus 1 is 13. i have two
numbers behind the decimal 13.5 so it's
going to be 13.5
and if i add these two together this is
going to be equal to the total surface
area that she has got to paint is going
to be 37.5
square well i guess they're not giving
us the units well 37.5
is good the total area of square units
of whatever the units happen to be